手づくりスーパーボール(ドン)
ピカ☆ピカ
ツクロゥ！キミダケノォ！カラフルスーパーボォゥル！
ハズマセェルトヒッカァルゥ！
手順を組んでちゃんと作れば、
光るスーパーボールが作れるらしいです。
やるしかねぇ―
バン！バン！バン！バン！
あぁ～
手づくりで！光るスーパーボール！作れるなら!
でかいの作ろうや！
バン！
☆～
♪～～～～～～～
ﾋｯｯヵｧﾙｩｩｹﾞｰﾑｽﾞ。（おかしなくしゃみｗ）
これを中に入れると光るということですね。
（ひとまず開封）
あぁ
おっしゃー！
普通の作り方だと、
専用のケースがあります。
このケースに玉をこうやってセットして、
こういう感じで被せて、
この中に好きなパウダーを入れて、
水を入れたコップに入れて、
ひっくり返して水を切ったら、
できあがり。
という流れなんですけどMO!
ﾎﾟｯ↑ﾎﾟｯ↓ﾎﾟｯ↓
私はそんな甘いことをしない!
そう!なぜなら私は
スーパーボウラーHajime!
そんな簡単なことを私はしない!
ﾍｯﾍｴｴｴｪｪｪ
やべえほんとおかしい人と間違われるな。
ホントにこれ多分説明書何もないんで、
これ結構簡単なんですよ。
要するにこれ水につけたらスーパーボールになるっていうものらしいので、
一先ずこのパウダー全部を何かに詰めなければいけない。
というわけで今回このスーパーボールの粉を入れるケースの代わりに何かないかと思ったところ、
あ゛ああああああああああああああああやってもーたこれは
はい、風船しかないなと思いました。
この風船を使って!
風船って膨らむんでなるべくこの中に粉を入れて、
粉の中にこの光るスーパーボールやらも入れて、
今日は!光る巨大スーパーボールを作って見ようと思います。
まずこれを膨らませなきゃいけない。
フゥゥゥゥゥゥゥゥゥゥゥゥゥ
パンッ
あ゛わ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛
やりましょう。
何処まで入れられるかってのがポイントですね。
わぁこれ厳しい戦いになりそうだな。
あぁでも全然入る。
あぁ…一応光ってますな。
フゥゥゥゥゥゥ
これぐらい入ってほしいんだよな…。
これぐらい沢山入ればこの大きさのスーパーボールができるっていうわけなんで、
うわっ、あぁやばいやばい。
なんかやばいやばい
完全にこれはヤバい
ﾌﾞﾎｫｰｯﾌﾟ
これ厳しくね?
ほらなんかもうやばい中途半端なところでヤバい。
あ、あぁ、落ちろ!
あぁぁ！穴開いちゃったあ゛あ゛あ゛!!
作戦変更!
風船はちょっと難しそうなのでスーパーの袋でやりましょう。
普通にこうすると丸じゃないんですけど、
両端を抑えれば丸っぽくなるんで
それでいいのかな？
袋に粉を入れないと試合は始まらん!
サッー!(迫真)
や゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛
たあ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛
や゛あ゛
よし、はい、全部入りました。
一回混ぜましょうか。
おぉー！
いい感じじゃないでしょうか!
結構綺麗に混ざりましたね。
このままやっても綺麗な丸にはならないので、
光るボールちゃんと入れないと
一先ずこれだけ入れときますね。
わぁ、埋め込めばいいんだよな中に。
後はこれの形を整えて、
ちゃんと、ボールになるようにします。
ガムテープ、ガムテープ
もう大体でいいよ。
一先ずボールの形して跳ねてればスーパーボールなので、
スーパーボールっぽい形に仕上がればOKな気はしております。
近づけたい。
形的にはかなり丸に近づいたので
ここでポイントなんですけども多分このまま浸けても出来ないんですよ。
何でこれ水に浸すと言いますと、
これよく見ると微妙にね、穴が開いてるんですよ。
多分この穴から水が入ってきて固まってスーパーボールになるので、
これもねちゃんと穴を開けて水を通さないとスーパーボールにならないので
ちょっとだけ、穴を開けます。
あやべ、結構開けちゃった。
OKです。そこそこ穴開けたので
これを早速水に浸して
巨大な光るスーパーボールを作りましょう!
ｯﾀｧｰ!(゜∀゜)
えーちょっと全然入ってなくね?
だめだこれちょっと足りない。
こっちに移るぜ!
あ、ちょっと浮いちゃうなぁ。
浮いちゃっていいのかこれ。
これで暫く放置しよう。
ｻﾙﾍﾞｰｼﾞ└(՞ةڼ◔)」
水を切らなきゃいけないんでここを切っちゃいます。
アァ怖い…。
逆さにしておいて、こうですね。
このまま5分間放置します。
暫し待たれよ!
ここからはケースから取り出して約10分間放置して乾燥させてください。
あぁ、あぁあぁ…おぅ?
あぁ?あぁぃえぇぇ?
うぅうぅいぇえぇえぇ??
うぃえぇ?うぃえぇ。
うぅえぇ…
はいというわけで無事取れました。
部分にもよるのですがかなり硬くなってる感はある。
もう暫くお待ちください。
いいよ大分スーパーボールっぽい形にはなってる。
後は本当貴方次第ですよ。
僕はもう…何で取れてる?
では10分待ちましょう。
ﾊｧｯ!(゜∀゜)
はいというわけで完成しました!
こちらが大量の手づくりスーパーボールで作った巨大な光るスーパーボールです!
悪くないっすよ!行けますよこれ!
弾力はね、すっげーあるんですよ。
これたぶん行けますよ!
光るかそして、
ちょっと待ってここで、ここで、
叩いたら、叩いたら光る
ほら!
他の部分は?
ほかの、他の部分は?
他の部分も光ってほしい。
すげー…部分的。
部分的ですけどちゃんと光っております。
俺さ、もうちょっと沢山入れた筈なんだけどなんか、
ここなんかこう…ここだけしか光んないね。
まぁいいでしょう!!
光ってることに変わりはありません!
問題はここからです。
これが本当に、スーパーボールとして跳ねるかどうか!
バァン(1回目)
バァン(2回目)
バァン(3回目)
あぁぁあぁあぁあぁあぁ…あぁ…あぁ…
あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛いてぇ!!
ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑
（今回は少し早回しでお送りします）
ﾍﾟｰ→ﾍﾟﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟー↑ﾍﾟｰ↓
（いつもより早めにお送りしています）
ﾍﾟ↗ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟｰｰｰｰ↗
ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟｰ↗ﾍﾟｰ↓
（いつもより早めにお送りしています）
ﾍﾟ→ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟｰ↗ﾍﾟｰ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↓
ﾍﾟ→ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟｰ↓ﾍﾟｰ↑ﾍﾟｰｰｰｰｰ↓(ﾍﾟｰｯ↑ﾍﾟｰｯ↓ﾍﾟｰｯ↓ﾍﾟｯ↓)
（いつもより早めにお送りしています）
ﾍﾟ・ﾍﾟ・ﾍﾟ・ﾍﾟﾝ☆
（今回は少し早回しでお送りしました）